peu la paix deux poursuivis depuis trois
mois par la cession des nations unies
réuni à paris et dans le sud robert
schuman ministre français des affaires
étrangères devait saluer la dernière
séance en se félicitant que les délégués
de 52 nation et voulait choisi paris
pour édicter la nouvelle déclaration des
droits de l'homme
nous considérons nous en fait il ya là
une espèce d'hommage rendu aux dépens
séculaire que l'esprit français dans la
recherche d'une fête universelle
[Musique]
même soirée les différents délégués
devaient aller présenter leurs
remerciements pour l'accueil reçu à
paris à monsieur vincent auriol
qu'entouraient messieurs cueille et
andré marin après la cession de chaillot
de nombreux problèmes restent sans
solution
la page de l'onu risque d'être encore
longue et pénible c'est justement contre
ces lenteurs que quelques jours
auparavant gare et d'un vice premier
citoyen du monde s'est élevé à la
tribune du vélodrome d'hiver
nous n'avons point de fusion sur les
pipis compter que nous attend mais
notamment choisir entre les piquants tlm
à chaque donateur
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai choisi
si monsieur les ventes sont au fond
d'accord le désir de paix est partout
mais où en sont les chemins
[Musique]